♪ Smoking cigarettes and
watching "Captain Kangaroo" ♪
♪ Tell me I've nothing to do ♪
♪ It's good to see you I must
go I know I look a fright ♪
- Mother f-
Narrator: You don't
have to be a movie buff.
Maybe you don't even
like movies that much.
But everyone has heard of
the name Quentin Tarantino.
He is, without a doubt,
one of the most celebrated
directors of our time,
with each of his eight iconic works
making a profound impact
on the history of cinema
and inspiring generations of filmmakers
with a vastly new style
and approach to filmmaking
that can only be described
as Tarantino-esque,
which, by the way, is
now an official entry
in the Oxford English Dictionary.
So, what makes the films of
Quentin Tarantino so special?
Many often cite his razor-sharp dialogue.
- You gonna bark all day, little doggy?
Or are you gonna bite?
Narrator: The often graphic,
yet stylized, violence.
Or his use of nonlinear
narrative structure.
But what truly sets him apart
from every other filmmaker
is the way in which he
steals from other movies.
And that's not just a figure of speech.
In a 1994 interview with Empire magazine,
Tarantino said, "I steal from
every single movie ever made."
Tarantino's visual references to movies
have become his trademark.
Some of these references
are merely hinted at.
- The D is silent.
- I know.
Narrator: While others are
almost identical replications.
For this reason,
he's been the center of
controversy for many years.
For example, in 1997, his
debut film, "Reservoir Dogs,"
was under heavy scrutiny after a critic
accused Tarantino of plagiarizing
the 1987 Hong Kong crime
film "City on Fire."
The final 20 minutes of "City on Fire"
is essentially identical to
the plot of "Reservoir Dogs,"
and there are shots and
moments scattered throughout
that directly resemble each other.
Including this famous
Mexican-standoff sequence.
(shouting in a foreign language)
But it's not just in this film.
Almost all of Tarantino's eight films
have a main source of inspiration.
For "Jackie Brown," it was
the 1974 film "Foxy Brown."
For "Kill Bill," the 1973
Japanese film "Lady Snowblood."
And his "Inglourious Basterds"
is, in a lot of ways,
similar to the 1967 war
film "The Dirty Dozen."
And on top of that, each film
has more visual references
to at least another dozen movies.
Many consider these similarities homages,
a practice as long as the
history of cinema itself,
a way for Tarantino to pay respect
to the movies he loves.
But Tarantino explicitly denies this.
In the same interview, he goes on to say,
"Great artists steal.
They don't do homages."
It's a quote that closely
resembles words attributed
to another famous artist: Pablo Picasso,
who's often quoted as having said,
"Good artists copy,
and great artists steal."
To understand why and
how Tarantino steals,
it's important to
understand his background.
Tarantino's career in film
didn't start in a classroom
or even a movie set, but a video store,
where he worked as a clerk
and gained a reputation
for his almost encyclopedic
knowledge of cinema.
In other words,
Tarantino was never
taught how to make a film.
Instead, he learned how to
make films by watching them,
which makes it natural that imitation
became his main source
of inspiration and style.
In fact, if you take a look
at most of Tarantino's screenplays,
they begin with a list of filmmakers
whom the stories were
inspired by and dedicated to.
I think the reason why
Tarantino is so proud
to admit that he is stealing
is because he accomplishes
something with it
that no other filmmaker
is quite capable of:
creating something new.
And as paradoxical as it may sound,
Tarantino's movies have a
sense of originality to them,
despite their many sources of inspiration.
This is why Tarantino is often hailed
as one of the quintessential
filmmakers of postmodernism.
Postmodernism in film describes an era
when filmmakers began questioning
the ways in which mainstream
movies are made and told
and began making movies that
went directly against it.
One of the central tenets of postmodernism
is the idea that nothing is new in art;
everything is recycled and
reused over and over again.
"Reservoir Dogs" might have
stolen the Mexican standoff
from "City on Fire," but
"City on Fire" also stole it
from the 1966 film "The
Good, the Bad and the Ugly."
And "Pulp Fiction" is no exception;
it's chock-full of references
to classical movies,
especially movies from the
French New Wave movement,
one of the most influential movements
in the history of cinema,
in which young filmmakers
also tried to challenge
the traditional method of filmmaking.
Its famous dancing sequence
was inspired by this sequence
from the 1964 film "Band of Outsiders."
And the choreography
closely resembles this scene
from the 1963 film "8 1/2."
But that's not the only
source it steals from.
John Travolta's dance was inspired
by this scene from 1966
adaptation of "Batman,"
while Uma Thurman's dancing resembles that
of a cat in the 1970 animated
film "The Aristocats."
And throughout the rest
of the film as well.
The mysterious suitcase that
carries the plot of the film
is a replication from
the 1955 American film
"Kiss Me Deadly."
And, of course, this scene was inspired
by Alfred Hitchcock's "Psycho."
What makes Tarantino so special
is that he never steals from one source.
He rather steals from multiple
sources spanning decades
and then stitches them together
to create something new.
It's a technique known as pastiche,
a vital element in postmodernism.
Most people are more
familiar with this technique
through another medium: music,
and especially in the hip-hop genre,
where artists use sampling
to take part of an existing song
to create something new.
♪ You said you'd care for care for me ♪
♪ Said you'd be there for me ♪
♪ Care for me ♪
♪ I know you care for me ♪
♪ There for me there for me ♪
♪ Said you'd be there for me ♪
And just like Tarantino,
it's been the subject of
controversy many times.
Tarantino's pastiche works so
well because of two reasons.
One is his understanding of
the subject he's stealing from.
More often than not, homages in movies
are a shallow and vain attempt
at imitating an iconic moment,
and they rarely serve a purpose.
But Tarantino's references
are often seamless
and easy to miss because
they enhance the scenes
and the genre he experiments with.
And if you take a look
at Tarantino's career,
each of his eight films is a tribute
to a specific genre
and movement in cinema.
"Reservoir Dogs" is a pastiche
of the gritty Hong Kong crime
films, and "Pulp Fiction"
is based on the unconventional
French New Wave movement.
"Jackie Brown" basis itself
off the '70s' controversial
blaxploitation films,
while "Kill Bill" is
reminiscent of the classical
Japanese samurai and
Chinese kung fu movies.
"Death Proof" pays tribute to low-budget
exploitation movies,
while "Inglourious Basterds"
references World War II cinema.
And his two most recent
films, "Django Unchained"
and "The Hateful Eight," are modern takes
of the Italian spaghetti Westerns.
Tarantino seamlessly
blends all these genres
and inspirations through his
unique vision and writing.
This is where his razor-sharp
dialogue comes in.
- Gentlemen.
You had my curiosity,
but now you have my attention.
Narrator: It's not an exaggeration to say
that Tarantino's films are essentially
readaptations of
classical films and genres
that take place in a world of Tarantino,
where violence, injustice, sex,
and satirical cynicism flourish.
Quentin Tarantino perhaps
knows better than anyone
that you don't have to
look far for inspiration.
Most of the time, it might be somewhere
close and familiar to us.
My guess is that, for Tarantino,
it's in the aisles of VHS tapes
that he grew up watching as a child.
Tarantino proudly plays the role
of a masterful thief of cinema.
And as long as he continues
to make a masterpiece out of them,
it's the kind of thievery I'd
be more than happy to accept.
- You know something, Utivich?
I think this just might be my masterpiece.